25 jours se sont écoulés depuis le
décollage de la fusée SLS et la capsule
Orion un voyage autour de la Lune très
satisfaisant pour les responsables de la
NASA mais le vrai test pour Orion était
le retour dans l'atmosphère terrestre
avec une nouvelle manœuvre on a joué sur
le fait que on a fait un premier rebond
sur l'atmosphère pour freiner tout
doucement la capsule puis ensuite entrer
directement dans l'atmosphère terrestre
ce que l'on ne fait pas par exemple pour
des capsules qui reviennent de la
Station spatiale internationale
les parois du vaisseau spatial doivent
résister à 2800 degrés Celsius un
bouclier thermique de 5 mètres de
diamètre le plus gros jamais construit
assure la protection de la capsule son
bon fonctionnement garantit l'avenir du
programme Artemis c'est la lune aurait
un rôle important à jouer pour le futur
de l'exploration spatiale d'abord pour
servir de base de relais vers d'autres
planètes comme la planète Mars
deux heures devaient s'écouler avant le
repêchage et le remarquage de la capsule
Orient pour permettre la collecte de
données sur l'état du vaisseau qui s'est
aventuré dans l'espace à plus de 430 000
km de la Terre c'est l'équipage
spécialisé du ussland un navire de la
marine américaine positionné au large de
la base Californie depuis samedi qui est
chargé de récupérer la capsule des eaux
du Pacifique
le 11 décembre semble être une date de
prédilection pour les événements
d'exploration spatiale une fusée de
Space ex décollée aujourd'hui à Cap
Canaveral pour lancer un alunisseur de
l'entreprise japonaise
icepace cette compagnie privée vise
l'exploration robotique à faible coût et
a conçu un alunisseur qui consomme moins
de carburant deux entreprises
canadiennes profiteront de cette mission
pour tester la résistance de leur
technologie sur la lune ce sont les
entreprises vraiment entre elles qui ont
transigé et ça c'est ce qu'on va voir de
plus en plus à l'avenir avec la
commercialisation avec les coûts de
l'accès à l'espace qui diminue et puis
il y a 50 ans les astronautes de la
mission Apollo 17 marchaient sur la lune
ce sont les derniers à avoir foulé le
seul lunaire ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Montréal